Continental Tire Coach's Corner brings
us the head coach of the Milwaukee Bucks
Mike Budenholzer who won last night beat
the Celtics they have the best record in
the NBA coach good morning how are you
I'm great guys how you doing doing okay
felt had a little playoff atmosphere
last night did you feel that last night
with the Celtics yeah you know certainly
the defense would still like to play
honesty I think both teams were really
great defensively I am neither of us
could read in one or get a rhythm
offensively so that's how it is
sometimes in the playoffs and you know
the crowd the atmosphere at Spicer has
been great this year so good to win a
close game like that I don't know how
concerned you are right now about this
but it feels like you your team wants to
get out and go and Boston was trying to
make a little bit more of a half-court
game and and as you know having been on
all those great Spurs team when you get
to the playoffs
these teams you know they like to break
it you know becomes a half-court game a
little bit how concerned are you that
your team can they be ready for that
postseason when it feels like the
philosophy during the regular season is
to get out and go yeah obviously kind of
belief about the playoffs and certainly
the more we can play and transition the
faster we can play I think that's to our
advantage and we'll try and push that
you know through the playoffs but if it
you know slows down and becomes more of
a half-court game you know we think
we've got a lot of really good players
you know obviously honest it's pretty
special
you know whether he's been half-court
and playing a transition and grass and
blood and broke you know shooting three
so you know we feel like we're both to
win and play a lot of different ways a
lot of different styles when did you
know that
Yanis was going to be great two or three
years ago when I was on the sidelines
wondering how we were ever gonna stop
this guy in transition you know just
he's you know I think I don't know what
it was that he immersed you know few
years ago but certainly for me to have
this opportunity to work with him and
coach him it just you know watching him
this summer
his work ethic it's just it's phenomenal
he's in the gym all the time you know in
the weight room does an amazing job
there so you know you see the work this
summer and you start playing pickup
games and you know you just it it
becomes pretty apparent when you're
around him on a day-to-day basis how
special he is how long did it take you
to pronounce his name correctly yeah I'm
sorry you won't catch me saying it on
this interview so I think what do you
call him got it okay very easy yeah
star whatever he wants to be called just
don't make me say his last name what did
you learn
what did what's the one big thing you
learned from Gregg Popovich being on
that staff for so many years well you
know I took the time and effort he
presented you know getting to know and
genuinely care about them and and build
a relationship for them so that then you
can coach them you know I think if you
don't do that give your life your life
yourself life might be a little shorter
but I think the way he felt
relationships not just with Tim Duncan
and Manu and Tony and you know the but
really our 1 through 15 the whole roster
throughout the organization he's just
he's great about doing that and then
everything else I think kind of falls in
place after you do that so I think a lot
of us that were around him and learn
from them that's one of the biggest
things you take away if I give you Tim
Duncan and the Greek freak same age how
would you take do that come on
no I mean it's they're both incredible I
feel so fortunate have been around to
both I don't know who you take one and
then I'll just I'll go with whoever you
pick I'll take Duncan okay if I the
greatest power part of all time so I
think it's no disrespect to y'all no
it's not
that's bid but he did I guess the
difference is that back when Tim played
your big man didn't have to shoot
outside didn't have to shoot threes and
but nowadays it feels like everybody is
adding that to their repertoire so in
and you know Yanis is gonna have to do
that eventually but and if he does he's
gonna hone the league but I think the
way Tim played the way the game was back
then you know and that might be where
the answer is though coach where what
what era of basketball are we talking
about if it's today's game that I want
the Greek Frank if it's back then then I
want Tim yeah I know I mean that's a
good way of looking at it and there's
there's no diamond Timmy at 24 I think
you'd want a championship and you know
he was just so special and you know it
played four years of college ball but
you know he was an incredible player and
dominant in that era and you know his
his post game is footwork you the
fundamentals and you know off the
backboard he could shoot the 15 footer
off the backboard out to the three-point
line and called glass out there but uh
you know Timmy was special and certainly
you know feels like be honest is is a
belt similarly and you know has a
similar career path ahead of him
he's the the Bucks head coach Mike
Budenholzer joining us Dan Patrick show
before you joined the Spurs what was
your job I graduated from college I
wasn't played and coached one year in
Denmark so I was playing on a men's team
and coaching some women's team and I
basically a high school team so I was I
was living large in Denmark wait wait
how do you how are you discovered in
Denmark yeah well I don't know if I was
discovered but I you know it was a coach
pop he actually coached at Pomona Pitzer
where I played you know Division three
ball and so had a relationship with him
and you know connection with him and he
needed somebody to do the video work in
San Antonio gosh 25 years ago something
like that so I think if being discovered
in Denmark to be the video coordinator
for the Spurs
I don't know if that's the right wording
of it but that's kind of how it happened
and you were asked or you you averaged
what 27 a game when you were playing
over there in Denmark
yes that's like that's like average of
27 and like the YMCA League down on the
coin it's okay okay your offensive style
who plays in today's game the way you
did that one year in Denmark no idea
that's a mm I don't know
just JJ reddick somebody like that he
could see like I was a shooter
were you the Steph Curry of Denmark okay
let's go staff well congrats you were
coach of the year already once where is
that award because you're probably going
to win it again this year yeah on my
desk in my office at the house yeah that
was a special season and you know very
appreciative of that opportunity and you
know I'm just glad to be here in
Milwaukee now I got a heck of a team and
just loving it and you know excited
about these last you know 20 25 games
seeing how we can finish you up and get
ready for the playoffs do you think your
you can go toe-to-toe with Golden State
in the seven games here I mean are you
confident looking at that roster
honestly that you could beat Golden
State I mean the one thing that we
really believe in is our defense it's
just you know I feel like we've done it
on a consistent basis you know for
however many games it is and if you can
guard you give yourself a chance against
don't say it I mean I know some people
think they are unguardable and a lot of
those people are probably closer to
right but you know we feel like
defensively we got a lot of guys that
can really get after and can you know
handle different matchups and those guys
are special but you know if you don't
think you can beat them and you know
you're in the league you're you probably
should be doing something different so
we'd love that opportunity we love that
chance to match up with them and beat
them coach good to talk
the questions will be a little tougher
the next time I talk to you though I
know I might I might tell my guys I
can't do this Thank You coach Mike
Budenholzer
yeah I'm sorry you know it's everyday
Super Bowl we aren't the floor briefed I
did I did I was ready to play game I
picked him up at 3/4 court their
Continental Tire Coach's Corner proud to
be the exclusive tire the Dan Patrick
show no matter where you drive what you
drive how you drive Continental designs
tires for what you do for more
information visit Condell entire calm
Continental Tire for what you do for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]